good morning John almost 10 years ago I
got on stage wearing a lanyard in the
worst way possible and told a room full
of people something that I still think
is true you have no obligation to your
former self there is one person I can
say objectively that I am smarter than
and it is me four years ago he knew like
all the things that I currently know
except less and he had all the life
experiences that I currently have except
fewer so why do I have an obligation to
a guy who not only is dumber than me but
literally does not exist
if the wisdom of the last 10 years said
knowing full well that I am as that guy
10 years ago said smarter than him I
could add some Nuance to that statement
yes my former self is dumber than me no
they don't exist but I am also just a
story that I tell to myself about myself
that's what I am and so there is
something kind of tricky about having no
obligation to my former self it is easy
I think too easy these days sometimes to
lose connections to our past to our
friends to our communities to our
families to our places and our Nations
and our religions and our histories
because ultimately it is you know
probably true that those things are
arbitrary we just happened into them and
maybe good maybe bad there are easier
things in life to do than to feel
connected to those things like Tick Tock
is the easiest thing right smartphone
games are very easy doing what you got
to do to get your work done it's easy to
prioritize that because you got to pay
the bills the kinds of Investments that
we make in connection I think are harder
if in part because they're not necessary
we are not obliged to maintain them now
some of them we are we feel that
obligation and sometimes we don't this
is very different for different people
but I think the amount of obligation
that we feel to our former selves to our
communities to our families I think it's
safe to say that even if it's high for
you it is on average lower for society
as a whole than it was 50 years ago
John when I was in high school I was a
bit of a punk or I like to think of
myself that way I listened to the dead
milk van and rancid an Operation Ivy in
The Clash and I did not want to have a
normal standard life because you know of
course I didn't I was a high school
student but I definitely didn't want to
be a businessman I didn't want to be a
lawyer and I remember having the thought
many times that when I was 40 years old
I wanted to get a mohawk because that
would prove that I had a job where you
could get a mohawk which would mean that
I had succeeded in the 17 year old
Hank's version of what a cool life was
and honestly that's dumb it's silly
until quite recently I had a job where
getting Mohawk would have made my job
and the jobs of my peers harder it was
just like a little not like
substantially but enough but that
doesn't mean that I didn't think about
it I totally did I thought about what I
owe that former version of myself and my
thought was you know nothing he's dumber
than me and he doesn't exist but look I
am a story that I tell to myself and 17
year old me is a vital part of that
story I am not him but I love him I care
about him I care about and love a lot of
people who don't exist anymore whether
they've died or they've just changed
like I care about and love
20 year old Catherine and she's not that
same person anymore but I still love 20
year old Catherine and I also love 43
year old Catherine
17 year old me was so certain and
passionate and scared and wild and often
very kind he was a good guy he was kind
of wonderful and he became me and I feel
like I was given an opportunity this
week to honor him so here I am John I do
not have no obligation to my former self
I have the amount of obligation to my
former self that I want to have and I
want to have some
John I'll see you on Tuesday